hello from the future of koh samet in
wooden china i'm torah grapple research
scientist at deep mind i'm joined here
by a jingly former Ford and professional
player hello
so we had a very special format today
for the first game can you tell us about
that yes the first game was parable
format where two human players each of
them came up with Iphicles and then they
really had to work as a team but they
were not allowed to discuss with each
other so fascinating and how did that
work out so it was really interesting to
see how the human players were like
trying to adjust to the IFF style and in
that process I believe the players
learned a lot of different things
Oh fascinating so let's look at an early
position what happened here in the top
right corner let's write so in this game
when black came over here we all
expected why to push over here because
the normal sequence and black would
extend white would jump but then this to
take you over here wouldn't really
coordinate with this part because when
black pushes white need to enter this
way and let can even push inward and
with this shape this white would be
somewhat over concentrated so when black
comes over here this result would be
play favourable for black right so white
play the different moves then that's
right so at this point it was either
goes turn in white team and I forgot to
this one space jump which is often
considered a bad move that's because
when black pushes here and then presses
white has to come out and then when
black cuts this is me I situation where
white has to give up either these two
stones or this one stone right but in
this particular situation it worked out
remarkably well can you show us how yes
that's right
so this situation was special because
after like capture this one's the
on this blacks a good influence was
somehow reduced by these White's
position already and also because this
was leather white could get to moves
around here
so when whitey came over here it will
black answered then white could save
this one stone right so that's why black
had to come over here and we can see
that still these white stones are
somehow limiting the blacks influence
toward this area and then white could
come over here and make a second attack
that's right absolutely
yes thank you okay so here a little
later in the same game another
interesting situation arose can you
explain what happened that's right
so after black came over here white
played here and this move over here is
looking at blacks weakness so if black
entered here to reinforce this weakness
why two would extend here making a good
shape in the side but it is somewhat
unavoidable for black because this pet
over here would be too severe yes in the
extra game black played here which was a
amazing timing in my opinion because
oftentimes when you see this invade on
white needs to let this black connect to
the corner in order to keep this white
shape but if white did bet in this
situation by connecting to the corner
blood would this blacks weakness over
here would be naturally weakened so for
example after this one because the
corner is already quite safe
when white needs to come out over here
to secure this group black could choose
this one and then this one wouldn't have
much meaning for white so white would
have to choose the different variation
here that's right so that's why why
didn't want to let black connect to this
corner in the actual game white exchange
it disattach
and then hannett so that if black not
here
white would plug this one and then when
like a terrace instead of connecting
here why do would choose this cut and
after it is black can save this group
right but there is still this weakness
and then also white can have a better
shape in the center so this was a whites
plan to do like this right but that's
also not what happens then that's right
yes and because white had this plan
instead of blocking this corner black
chose to come out here and then white
exchange it this one
if black blocked here then it would
become the same sequence fruit but like
connected here and then white hurried
this one so even 30 it became a big
exchange where why it's got this corner
and then black got the outside so
Hannity here connect it would have been
nice if white could come out here but
then the capturing race between the
corner and the outside would have been
somewhat difficult for white right yes
so like this it would have been not
possible for white so I had to come back
to the corner here and then black block
white had to connect and then black
block and then let block here at the
postgame press conference family told us
that I thought this video was good for
black right yes because erdo white cut
the whole corner flex outside was really
good and also black that sent
and this one wasn't as a white had to
take this one and then with here right
yes got the corner territory but black
ended up with a lot of strength on the
outside that's right yes thank you so
later in the game there was an
interesting development here on the
lower left can you explain what happened
that's right
so after black beauty's influence came
into here to attack these two stones and
then we all thought this was a good move
right but at the press conference fun we
told us that actually I forego was
expecting this move and the merits of
this move would be yes and this move is
very difficult to think because first
over it's very high to the 5th line and
also when you think about chasing these
two stones somehow eliminating the eye
space is the first intuition you have
but this move is on globally looking at
all the Sun Plex influence the whole
board and somehow because of these
center moves why cannot come outside so
even if white could live inside leg
would be able to build a huge moil in
the center and that would give blacks
big advantage so that was much better
move than this invasion and when ghuli
saw this move for the first time he said
that he wouldn't have thought about this
move once I saw it he thought it was
quite impressive yeah it's very good to
see that professionals can learn from
alphago that's right yes great thank you
thank you